welcome to book TV's afterwards I'm
Nancy McLain a historian of the 20th
century us at Northwestern University
and our guest today is Bethany Morton
assistant professor of history at the
University of Georgia and author of the
new book to serve God and Walmart the
making of Christian free enterprise
which is being published this spring by
Harvard University Press first of all I
just want to say Bethany congratulations
this is an extraordinary work of history
I have read a great deal about Walmart
over the last decade or so and I just
picked up your book and it transformed
my understanding of this phenomenon the
story that you tell is rich and it's
gripping the details are sometimes
amazing there are surprises you know all
throughout and the analysis is really
bold and original so I think what you
have here gives us all a lot to think
about and I think this is going to be a
really rich discussion today this is a
book that ranges through southern
history and the development of
capitalism and the Ozarks and religious
but revivalism and women and changes in
the family economy the expansion of free
enterprise to Latin America in the 1970s
and 1980s so there's just so much going
on here I hope to be able to give our
readers and listeners a sense of all of
it what I thought would be helpful to do
is just kind of start with the big
picture of the book and what you're
doing here and then then get into some
of the particulars but first of all I
think in terms of the big picture most
readers are going to know that Walmart
is the biggest company on the planet now
but few of us I think realized just how
big it is
and what a player it is economically if
you tell us in the early pages of the
book
that if the if Walmart were an
independent country it would be it would
have a 30th 30th largest economy in the
world so it is just a stunning behemoth
of an economic power yeah so I mean I
think we should talk maybe a little bit
about the scale but also one of the
things that I think is so new and
provoked provocative about your book is
that you make this argument that just as
the Ford Motor Company shaped the
industrial era that brought us you know
the Great Depression deal but you know
all the things that that that
characterized you know so much of the
20th century you make an argument that
Walmart is shaping the new era of global
service and in changing culture and
politics and everyday life so just give
us if you will it kind of a big picture
of what how big heart is and sort of how
it's affecting well that was exactly the
analogy that was so useful for me
because I'm one of these concrete
thinkers and to try to imagine the shift
from a sort of industrial economy to a
post-industrial economy what does this
mean
I needed a image a group of characters
and actors that would make that concrete
and Walmart those of us who grew up in
the South got used to seeing it I think
a lot earlier than it burst own to
international attention and so we were
getting a sense of how it was reordering
parts of our lives
early owned and if you think of you know
the first half of the merit of the 20th
century being so shaped by
industrialization and by the assembly
line and Charlie Chaplin in modern times
these kinds of images Walmart was doing
the same thing but with a completely
different cast of characters and with
completely different sort of animating
ideas and a different geography and I
think there's been a lot of marvelous
reporting in the business press thank
goodness about how it has reshaped
economic relationships around the planet
that the the kind of offshoring
phenomenon Walmart would be China's
sixth largest trading partner if it were
again an independent country those kinds
of relationships have I think worked
their way into public consciousness so
it was an easy starting point now I
started looking at her in 2002 at the
point where Walmart for the first time
became the largest company on the planet
and this was a really signal moment I
think that that a lot of people grasped
at the time because it was the first
time a service provider ie a place where
women in blue smocks asking if they can
help you replaced big heavy industry
extractive
oil companies motor companies this kind
of thing and the effects of that seemed
so far-reaching
in so many parts of people's lives that
it seemed like a good way to just get a
core sample from an awful lot of
different changes so I was really kind
of grateful to to the company for
presenting itself so clearly as a
laboratory for these things I mean it
did great well we I want to come back to
this question about women because that's
one of the most interesting themes I
think in the book but I wanted to go
back a little bit to the early years too
because this is a work of history about
Walmart and so much of the writing about
Walmart you know as you mentioned is by
you know economists or social scientists
or other people who don't have a long
view and when you do come at this with
the long view you get such a different
picture and so one of the things that
struck me in reading the book is that
Walmart grew up in the region of the
country that was known as the heart of
anti-monopoly sentiment that was a
citadel of the People's Party and the
populist movement and the fight against
the chain stores in the 1920s so how did
this happen how did we get from the anti
chain store campaign to the biggest
chain store in the world you know that
was kind of a shock to start looking at
the early sites of not only of Walmart
stores this is in the ozarks region of
Northwest Arkansas on southwest Missouri
the the kind of it's sort of a redheaded
stepsister to Appalachia and sort of our
sense of mountain the mountains south
but a wonderful place and when you look
at places not only where Walmart stores
started but where their infrastructure
got started some of the same place names
started popping up as with the most
concerted effort of a different an
alternative economic vision that we
talked about the populace at the end of
the 19th century where people were from
these rural areas were saying no there's
an expanded role possibly for government
in the economy there's there are serious
problems with an economy organized
around major corporations and yet here
they were the seedbed of what was now
the
largest corporation in the world which
means the largest one in history so
where how did that such a sort of
seemingly contradictory outcome take
place and this is kind of the the Thomas
Frank question of what's the matter with
Kansas if you want to put it in such
frankly political sense how did people
who were on at one point big fans of
using government power to rein in
corporate corporate power how did they
become such fans of Walmart of of this
mechanism so in the 20s the late 20s and
early 30s in fact some of these
descendants of the populace in these
same regions were not only fighting
large corporations they were fighting
specifically in the large corporation
model that would become Walmart that is
chain stores chain distribution so at
the time there was a great deal of
animosity for these outside actors
coming in with this foreign capital and
driving small businesses out and so
forth in yet these are exactly the
places where Walmart is taken to be kind
of a standard-bearer now of rural
America
and what you see at the time is oddly
the the sort of liberal establishment if
you will of the late 20s early 30s
arguing on behalf of the large
corporations and saying chain
organization is the most efficient and
therefore the most modern and oh yes
there are some labor problems but we're
very confident that chains are just made
for unions and unions will be welcomed
into chain stores because that's modern
and efficient and all these problems
with low wages and long hours and some
firms will be worked out and of course
it was exactly the opposite and what
really seemed kind of extraordinary at
the time was how much the anti chained
forces these small towns in the Ozarks
the battle was was being portrayed as a
religious battle in part that the anti
chained forces were were called the
fundamentalists and were being derided
sometimes in the National more liberal
press as as defending as being on the
same level as the the Scopes trial which
was a very recent memory at the time so
this this push on the one hand from the
kind of industrial north and the liberal
establishment to say these people need
to get a grip and figure out that
economic efficiency dictates that they
will ultimately be absorbed into these
large chain organizations and saying
that this was a religious position an
anti modern and and so those elements
were all present right from the get-go
and of course the the anti change for
says are defeated which which allows a
Walmart subsidy to arise but it does
cast the later story in very different
light if you understand that Walmart
before there was a Walmart had to win
this major battle to even exactly very
interesting let me just say I should
probably add for our listening audience
that you may be hearing a bit of buzz in
the background and seeing people walk by
behind us and that's because we're
meeting here at the organization of
American Historians
annual meeting in Seattle where
Professor Morton whom I'm speaking with
here is on on a panel and lots of other
historians are doing the things the
stories do we put together but I am
speaking with Bethany Morton who's the
author of to serve God and Walmart the
making of Christian free enterprise I
want to ask you also about how you did
your research you know I know you grew
up in Mississippi and you have some
access and maybe hear accent what's
helpful but I mean you are looking at
the most powerful company on the planet
and you're not necessarily giving them a
free touch on a lot of these questions
so how did you do your research how you
know what were your key sources did
people at Walmart talk to you
you know how did you get in you know for
people who are interested in
corporations as sort of major
international actors this is always the
big question right there's no Freedom of
Information Act that forces
privately-held companies to to make
their internal records known the way a
state actor is and so the more influence
that corporations have the the bigger of
a question this is for historians and
researchers generally that here are
these major forces in shaping our lives
and there's no particular reason why
they should let you in or talk to you or
show you anything at all so I had to try
to imagine suppose I got no access
whatsoever how could you tell a story
about a company that was undoubtedly a
major player over the last quarter of a
century worldwide and yet had no
particular reason to to invite a
researcher in so of course I started by
trying to address the company formally
and you know and your student your a you
know doctoral student there are people
who will take pity on such folk that
didn't really go anywhere but meanwhile
I had imagined this other set of sources
to be kind of a the donut if I couldn't
get at the hole so the places I wound up
successfully researching were more for
example the charitable efforts that
Walmart funds which are great places in
which people talk about what's important
to them and what they see themselves
doing in the larger sense so they're
actually a really wonderful source and
there's a lot more reason to imagine
access there the churches and the
religious institutions where people who
worked in Walmart worked for Walmart
gathered those are very welcoming places
and people are always willing to talk to
you about their faith if you're willing
to ask being from Mississippi was a big
help
because frankly I liked Arkansas I loved
living in the Ozarks and it would it was
funny sometimes to be back up at Yale
have people say oh gosh you know man I
really pity you down there in the
trenches and Arkansan say no I'm not
this place I mean many many friends
doing this and was very happy living
there going to church with people
meeting people I interviewed a lot of
folks who had worked over many years for
Walmart in lots of different positions
they were invariably had very
intelligent analyses had stories that
were incredibly enlightening and very
respectful of my interest and I think
just communicating to people that you
think what they did was important and
that it has had a major impact
historically is something that we don't
often remember I think as historians
matters to people there were parts of
this story that as you mentioned went
into Latin America I was treated like an
honored guest by many wonderful people
that I met in Central America and then
of course you know the archival record
is not confined just to internal
documents people would give me
for example the internal magazine from
my used to work in a library as a
periodicals assistant after college
before graduate school great training
these are actually publications that
wouldn't be bound because write them but
mind them and found these amazing things
in what are called you know house organs
the kind of publications that companies
put out to advertise them that's really
really rich yeah because you have
Tomatoes day to day work we spend most
of our looking lives at work people are
deeply invested in what they're doing on
the job and and particularly in these
early magazines from the 70s and early
80's it's a very unselfconscious kind of
self revelatory instinct so and I would
meet people who were mentioned in those
articles and they would introduce me to
other people and know that source was
is now publicly available I should
mention or available to the public
through an archive in Kansas flagler
productions has the full run now but at
the time they were kind of hard to get
your hands on and so I was grateful to
the people that would pass on their
copies and and explained to me what the
magazine had meant to people inside the
company some of the story you know
involves very public sources government
documents that kind of thing but a lot
of it was was a really fun treasure hunt
and and I learned a tremendous amount
yeah I really I felt in reading the bits
that you had from from the publication
that you really got inside the culture
you know and maybe you could just tell
us some of the stories the kind of
stories that were there that are what
people know of Walmart and the sort of
Sam Walton phenomenon and the way the
shop floor was run and some of the
relationships between managers and
workers could you just give us a feel
for what was in some of those early
records before it became this huge a
collaboration a big story I mean because
of course people's understanding the
company is now very much shaped by its
it's sort of post 1992-94 version but
from the earlier company you have to
think of these as stores that were sort
of replacing the town square sit in a
small town by small town and they were
frequently located in county seat towns
because of course farmers are a custom
in the south were accustomed to coming
in in you know mule wagons on Saturdays
and doing their doing their shopping and
also for that among many other reasons
Sam Walton was careful originally to put
these in county seat towns and you had
it performing the same function in many
places as the old town square people
would talk about how they loved working
at Walmart because and this is important
to say that the people I interviewed
were very insistent that this story get
out how much they appreciated working
for a company where they were taken
seriously they were treated with respect
where they had a chance to be at the
center of action in the town these
stores these early stores were very kind
of
in crazy sites there were country music
broadcast there were costume days
constantly all sorts of stunts just
reasons to bring people into the store
to treat it like a public space of
course a privatized public space it was
an important distinction but a way to
kind of make shopping entertainment and
make it a full family activity there's a
lot of emphasis on keeping it absolutely
and so a lot of people talked about how
working in that environment was really a
very good thing for them women whose you
know other careers was largely you know
performing household chores some of them
for pay your a minute and just remind
people that we're talking to Bethany
Morton who's the author of to serve God
in Walmart the making of Christian free
enterprise and you just hit on something
that I really wanted to hear more from
you about and that is this dimension of
the book which I just haven't seen in
any other study of Walmart and that is
your focus on women and on women as
really important actors in the story not
famous women but the women who shopped
at Walmart and the women who worked at
Walmart and you argue that they really
shaped this Corporation and the service
economy and that's kind of clean to make
but you know you persuaded me you have
to tell our listeners gonna be skeptical
well it's a question of how you you
conceptualize structuring a workplace
you know there's there's a lot of
critique right now and and rightly so
that the incorporation of so many women
into service workplaces hasn't really
been all it could have been from women
workers that in fact these remain
certainly at Walmart some of the lowest
paid worst benefits worst hours these
are not prestigious jobs these jobs
don't carry the kind of security
benefits and so forth that you would
hope would be part and parcel of working
in this country what a lot of people
from the earlier years particularly
we're seeing the slip we're moving out
of farm economies into these places
these are people who unlike in the urban
north where you had farm generations
going through
factories these are people going
straight into service and bringing a
whole different sense of what work is
about and if you think about it the
relationship I mean we're both in a
service job ourselves that most
Americans are ever since 1956 it's been
the majority of the workforce and what
does service work do that other kinds of
work don't require it's the creation of
that relationship between for us
teaching and our students for people in
other kinds of service jobs it's that
relationship between the service
provider and the client or the customer
and for so many people I mean it's easy
to say oh that's false consciousness
that's just a sideline people ought to
be more deeply invested in in more
concrete rewards and certainly we all
want to get paid and we all want to get
health insurance but for women in these
frontline service jobs they did
transform the workplace along according
to their priorities in the sense that
that relationship of service became not
only at the forefront of Walmart's
identity in the stores where these women
are both the service provider and the
customer and frequently people are one
on one day the week and one on the other
these are the same people but also it
became managerial gospel that sir and
this was not and this was not did not
come from the top it was not an
automatic development this was taught to
the upper management by these women in
the shop floor and for them as for us
the satisfactions of performing service
for someone else are not to be taken
lightly lightly you can see in business
literature in evangelical advise
literature this prioritizing of women's
work and of care and service for other
people working its way up from the
bottom and so to look at an onion eyes
Walmart store and say this is a failure
is to limit
I think our analysis of what's important
to people at their jobs and to fail to
extend to people and serve
jobs the same kind of respect for that
satisfaction of doing a good job that we
assume in so many other white-collar
service jobs so these women had a real
impact and you would hear from the
management saying you know the backbone
of Walmart is these women in their you
know late 30s to late 50s who are
department managers which is a
particular category of really the most
stable job in Walmart these motherly
women mothers grandmothers working these
jobs bringing the skills they had from
performing service work for their
families in these rural communities into
these service jobs and teaching that as
the fundamental set of skills and it was
recognized as skill you know we talked
about these as unskilled jobs that
anyone who's ever worked such a job
knows that there's no such thing as an
unskilled job you know it's just Walmart
was one of the few places where those
skills were called skills and recognized
if not always in the ways you would hope
at least very publicly very explicitly
and it had a real impact so a lot of
this one will say hey look we know we
weren't being paid well we know that
this is not the best deal under the Sun
but it wasn't the worst deal either when
you look at what the options were that's
one of the things I really appreciate it
in the way that the book was written is
that your overall approach is so
empathetic to all of the characters and
you really try to inhabit their worlds
and kind of understand things through
their eyes and so really engage their
own sense of the value of their work you
know in the case of these women and I
think that that really helps us to get
at this phenomenon in a way that we
haven't been able to before because
people haven't looked with that kind of
sort of judgment in looking in and not
that kind of empathetic view and and
somehow though you do manage to do both
because you also do talk about the fact
that Walmart now is facing the biggest
sex discrimination case in the world and
it is systematically frozen women out of
the higher management
positions and confine them to certain
places and yet you help us understand
why it is that so many women could still
be happy working for a company if it
does that I want to talk about one other
element before I think we'll need to
break that's related to this and this is
going back to the issue of Walmart
coming out of this region that was so
dead set against the chain stores and it
seemed to me that the discussion you
have of women and men in the workforce
and Families gives us new insight into
that too in the sense that the fact that
so much of the workforce was female made
the company not as threatening to those
ideas of manly independence as a chain
store might have been had they employed
all men had it been men who were working
on the shop floor and you know folding
the shirts and putting out things that
might have been a little less welcomed I
would think in the region that you're
talking about absolutely in the early
fight against chain stores in the 20s
and 30s
the one of the principal critiques of
the chain store was that it it was
unmanly work that you would take men who
ought in the natural order of things and
by this these lights ought to rise to
the status of running their own stores
and you know essentially an analogy to
running their own farm and being the
master of their their household that in
a chain operation you couldn't do that
that these men were permanently frozen
in these kind of low-level clerking
positions where they were always taking
orders and that this was really as in
your own work on the Klan in in Clark
County Georgia where I live there was a
great deal of anxiety about trapping
white men in these in these positions
and part of the genius of Walmart's
model which of course has been
replicated now all over the world in all
forms from maquiladoras from factories
on the border where young women assemble
you know tennis shoes to to wal-mart
itself the genius of it was to rather
than try to keep men in this position
and defend that which was not flying to
simply bring family structures into the
workplace and use them as a new source
of value because of course women have
always done this word
it's just been held outside of the of a
commodity relationship it's not paid so
to bring women and their traditional
familial work into a paid position
what's your competition no one else is
paying for this work no one's
recognizing it farm families are used to
the idea that everyone performs an
economic task this isn't the same as
having an ornamental wife at home whose
only job is to shop
everyone in Walmart country yes exactly
so this this model actually instead of
him instead of being a throwback really
was actually hyper-modern what you can
do if you start from a farm economy and
skip that factory moment is skip all of
the baggage of having a male breadwinner
who's somehow economically independent
and instead just bring that family
structure directly in the story and
that's exactly how people talked about
it that I spoke to that it was so much a
family relationship well you know
families include hierarchy they include
economic relationships they're not just
about sentiment but they do
sentimentalize they do bring human
relationships into that economic model
and that is not the worst of all worlds
for a lot of people it's interesting I'm
just sitting here thinking about the
early 19th century and the Lowell mills
you know and there was a twice when yeah
when industrial capitalism was
developing in America and here we'd had
this revolution and everyone a buddy
wanted to be you know sort of a free
holding into fell all the citizens and
franchise citizens wanted to be
independent free holding men to have you
know economic autonomy and power and so
how do you bring a factory system in
there and the way that problem got
solved or you know the circle got
squared in the early 19th century was
brought bringing in these young women
who never would have been allowed to
have economic independence anyway and
who at were seen as just working for a
brief period before they went off to get
married and so that guy the Lowell's
that I thought of when I found the the
Walmart internal magazine because you
know fortunately the Lowell little girls
were so literate that they left all this
documentation there's another moment
when you you know in the nineteenth
century you see people encounter factory
discipline for the first time and they
react
and they say a lot about it when you see
people encounter service discipline for
the first time they also have a lot of
great interest to say about it
that that now applies were you know most
of the American workforce so I think we
ought to be students of that encounter
that's great I think we're going to take
a brief break now and then pick up with
the interview with Bethany Morton who's
the author of to serve God in Walmart
the making a Christian free enterprise
and we're here at the meeting of the
Organization of American Historians in
Seattle afterwards and several others
c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with bethany
morton and nancy mcclain in a moment the
summer book TV is asking what are you
reading a lot of people think summer is
the time for light reading as far as I'm
concerned summer is the time to read the
big heavy books last year I tackled the
Fountainhead over a summer vacation this
year I am looking forward to finishing
Anna Karenina I tried to read it about
15 years ago and couldn't do it and I
came up with a new translation which I
started on vacation in February chipping
away at it but I'm about halfway through
and probably on vacation we'll be able
to finish most of it olive kitteridge
the new Pulitzer prize-winning novel by
Elizabeth Stroud my book love has took
that one I'm going to finally read
manhunt the Lincoln history by I James
swanson which has been out for a few
years now and a couple other things
either the the story of edgar sawtelle
which everyone else my family has read
and raved about or America America by
Ethan Canin
finally you know I guess some light
reading is called for and I hope to
finally tackle Twilight by Stephenie
Meyer I love the movie more than I
expected everyone says that the books
are even better to see more summer
reading lists and other program
information visit our website at book
tv.org
[Music]
afterwards with Bethany Morton and Nancy
McLain continues welcome back to book
TV's afterwards
I'm Nancy McLain a historian of the 20th
century United States at Northwestern
University and the author of a book
called freedom is not enough the opening
of the American workplace which looks at
the struggles for equality in the
workplace by various groups after World
War Two beginning with african-americans
mexican-americans and women and then the
conservative responses to those and
looks at how those really reshaped our
politics over the last 50 years and I
think through the research on that book
I somehow came to be sitting in this
chair having the chance to encounter a
wonderful new book by Bethenny Morten
who's here to talk about her book to
serve God and Walmart the making of
Christian free enterprise which is just
now being published by Harvard
University Press and one of the things
that you touched on in the earlier half
of our discussion that we didn't really
get into in depth that I really want to
focus on now is this whole issue of
religion this was news to me this
association between Walmart and religion
and just how powerful it is in the
history of the the growth of this
corporation and I confess I'm something
of an innocent on this front of me my
sense of Jesus is the Sermon on the
Mount yet you show how Walmart promoted
this idea of a nun quoting free
enterprise as Christian service and that
was challenging concept for a free
enterprise as Christian service yet you
make a very strong case for how
important evangelical Christianity has
been in the rise of this mega
corporation could you tell our listeners
something about that and well I have to
say I didn't work out looking for
religion in this story it was a surprise
to me as well Ralph Reed said the head
of one of the largest evangelical
organizations in the country
said a few years ago that if you want to
find if you want to reach evangelicals
on Sunday obviously you speak from the
pulpit but if you want to reach them on
Saturday you you go to Walmart and this
association between the company and an
evangelicalism in this country is is
very clear in the stores it's just not
part of the company's overt self
presentation and it's not in fact part
of the original Walmart family's own
history they were not in fact
evangelical activists in any way very
mainline Protestants but people in the
stores again have kind of changed the
meaning of both of shopping of service
work and of this largest corporation on
the planet to be very much a Christian
story a story about what you do for
other people a recognition that that the
work of service is work and it can be a
labor of love and that there are for
many Christians very ennobling
associations with that when I first
started encountering people kind of
bringing me to this I started going to
churches where many Walmarts my friends
there were a lot of people who invited
me along to different churches to sort
of see the our image of evangelical mega
churches these very large churches that
have grown up across the Sunbelt over
the last 30 years churches that organize
all kinds of community life for people
who are increasingly of course living in
suburbs driving a great deal of the time
shopping at Walmart and these are
institutions that kind of parallel in a
way Walmart's own growth in making the
work of serving other people a central
tenet one of the things that you you see
that that many scholars have written
about in changes in evangelical
Christianity in the last 30 40 years has
been an increasing emphasis own sort of
the relationship the people skills
the
personal relationship with Jesus that
people talk about in these churches it's
now much more important for most most
Christians than what we think of as
dogma and strict rules and careful
separation among different denominations
that there's been a real move for the
experiencial side of worship and that
people were reading the same advice in
Walmart stores and offices and in the
churches that many of these managers and
and frontline workers were going to -
the same advice the same sense of what
they want to do within these
institutions to bring people together to
have experiences rather than than a kind
of regimented formulated formulaic
experience for the the women working in
Walmart's who made service so central to
the company's own ethos there meanwhile
in Christian circles reconfiguring
Christian family life so at one point in
the 80s
Walmart is employing a director of
marriage and family living who's giving
advice to managers and saying go home
and look at the work that your wife's
doing in the household she's probably
got a job you know this is now the norm
for everyone but yet she comes home and
she puts herself out there she does this
work for you and for your children and
makes your house a nice place to be
why do you assume that she owes you that
work don't you have enough sense to come
home and thank her and using this kind
of recognition of that female work and
he's saying directly to these managers
do that on the work in the workplace
recognize that the work that the women
are doing for you in the home and on the
job both deserve recognition and praise
doesn't mean you're supposed to do it
doesn't mean it's supposed to be
particularly well remunerated but it
does mean that it's it's a proper role
but yet it is a role that is ennobling
that merits praise and so the whole
shift in
in many branches of evangelical
Christianity towards submission and
headship as a way to describes women's
relationships to their husbands has this
real parallel and they're definitely
talking to each other in these service
workplaces that says these values of
caring and service and everything these
are important for women and men these
are these are the supreme Christian
values the people who were doing them
best are these women in your home and in
your workplace in your workplace and you
need to affirm that and praise that and
recognize that and yeah now you know
you're still in charge you're still the
decision-maker you the the male head the
male manager but the real work here is
the work of service um you and I work in
in workplaces that are technically
gender-neutral that are technically
opened as your own work shows and yet
that's not what we hear at work right
you've got to give evangelical women
credit for ex transforming yes frankly
university doesn't even have maternity
leave
yeah there's no childcare there's no
recognition that those are part of all
of our work lives now right
and yet in these evangelical
relationships at home at work there's a
great deal of recognition for that it's
it's a victory that has not yet been won
in the larger culture and it has not
been completely won anywhere but when we
look at what's lacking in these
workplaces and in these settings I think
we also have to look at what has been
accomplished that was actually one of
the things that I I just found most
arresting in the book and and just
really um made me sit back and think
because you you do show that how these
women who have a really weak hand play
it so incredibly well and find these
resources in what their company needs
and in their churches in order to kind
of renegotiate the terms of the
relationships with these men who are
much more powerful than they are you
know in their lives whether it's their
managers on the shop floor or whether
it's their husbands at home and I just
thought that was a very
it was new to me to think about it in
that way and it was a very respectful
treatment that really I I would say they
seem to be almost the emotional core of
your book these women who are the
shoppers at Walmart and the workers at
Montmartre who are the majority of the
people in the pews at these evangelical
churches and what you're really showing
us is that they are finding in faith a
resource that lets them navigate this
pretty cruel new economy where they
don't have much provided for them they
don't have many resources and you do
that it didn't have very nicely but you
also have a very critical edge in this
book on some of the dimensions of other
dimensions of Christianity in the ways
that it's been harnessed by very
powerful economic actors and so maybe
you could talk about a little bit about
that side too because there's a very
empathetic portrayal of what's going on
at the grassroots but at the same time
you show the funding of you know some
very conservative Christian efforts and
the expansion of those efforts abroad
could you talk a little bit about that
side of it about the ways in which I
don't mean to put this too crudely but a
certain interpretation of evangelicalism
and of God and a believers relationship
to God worked really well for the
Republican rights larger project of
course this is the big question in the
conservative ascendancy that people have
talked about so much is how do you get
on the one hand this constellation of
values around religious conservatism
around issues of sexual control frankly
if you think of homosexuality and
abortion as the - you know as we say
hot-button issues how that particular
set of concerns became so closely
intertwined with a particular economic
vision when there's not on the surface
of it a necessary connection there and
historically there hasn't always been a
connection there and so the question for
many people who've done such a
productive work thinking about this has
been how did those get together and what
I found so revelatory with this was just
how necessary that connection was on the
level of
you know when we're living in a moment
where there are not so many state
services as there were a generation ago
where do you go for care where do you go
for delivery of services you go to
families the the rise and importance of
the family really parallels the
diminution of public services so there's
that logical connection but then also of
course Walmart and again this was in
part forced on me by the research model
that if you cannot walk into the company
and walk out with their file cabinets
where do you go and where I went was to
the philanthropic efforts that they
funded of those probably the most
important was students in free
enterprise but I wanted to ask you about
that because young people also play a
really interesting role in the story
well what you see again you've got
generations moving through from farms
through either these service jobs or
these management jobs and where they go
they go to small Christian colleges to
learn business to become white collar
professionals and so Walmart funded
through through a variety of vehicles a
number of small Christian colleges in
Arkansas and evangelical Sun Belt
companies more generally have these
relationships with many of these
colleges throughout the Sunbelt of
promoting what I call Christian free
enterprise through these growing
colleges of business in these in these
Christian colleges and so one part of
the book I spend in Christian business
schools looking at what's being taught
and how do those respects animate that
were marvelous places to study the how
nice animating values of service come to
be attached to this particular economic
vision of free enterprise and a lot of
it is well it's not forward date you
know small Christian colleges are
without an obvious support base they
don't have wealthy alumni they they
can't win you know a particle
accelerator or robotics laboratory when
you know when Sputnik suddenly means
that there's all this funding for
research
it's not a small college that's gonna
get it's not a small Christian college
so where they go and they find sort of
client bases
among these Sun Belt businessman
Christian businessmen largely many of
whom themselves don't have a college
education this is not true Sam Walton he
was college educated but and and the
Christian colleges approached them from
a gesture of respect and say we value
what you do we think you have could have
a hand in shaping this new economic
reality for the Sun Belt for the south
for the Southwest so Walmart
did this through these colleges and
through this organization students in
free enterprise which actually has a
much longer history in Texas that I get
into but which essentially was a vehicle
for having grass roots campus activism
in favor of free-market capitalism and
radical at theme parks sharing for
capitalism and treating cat and they use
this term set at some points at other
points they avoid it essentially but
they use capitalism as this maligned
undermined and it's the late 60s they
have a point
victimized and it's going to go down if
we leave it in the hands of people at
Columbia University or Berkeley you know
know that the country needs according to
this vision needs good good values
coming out of Christian business schools
and coming out of the experience of
these young people going out essentially
door-to-door trying to drum up support
for capitalism so they would have these
marvelously creative projects where they
would show for example you could have a
making of OPEC the pencil story oh it's
marvelous dramatization of one of Milton
Friedman's fables about with not he used
it other people created it about why the
invisible hand is such
miraculous development why the market
the fact that the market can organize
all these economic forces so Milton
Friedman deploys this fable of the
pencil Leonard read writes this little
story of how a simple pencil just this
very commonplace consumer item really
shows you the people who make the
graphite and the people who mill the
wood and so forth they don't know how to
put it all together they don't know how
to make a pencil they don't know how to
market it and move it around the world
and yet through the magic of the market
this all comes together and we are able
to write so students take this story
which was popularized by Milton Friedman
in his series and one student group came
up with a giant sort of dancing pencil
we went around to just student and it
was a big hit right what teacher
wouldn't have faced with the challenge
of trying to explain economics to grade
school children wouldn't be thrilled to
invite these young pro-capitalist
activists many of them from Christian
colleges the majority from these
Christian colleges to come in and teach
schoolchildren about the magic of the
market and about economic citizenship
and how all sorts of American values are
rooted in private property these are
concepts that that can be transmitted in
a very simple format of as entertainment
yeah and these are idealistic young
people rights the same generation as the
60s they're many of them Christian they
have a sense of greater purpose and
someone puts in front of them an
economic vision and says this is they
don't say this is how to get better
profits they don't say this is how to
rule the world through the world's
largest company they say this is how to
make people's lives better you can be an
agent of making people's lives better by
helping transform the world
in the image of free enterprise and you
know idealistic energetic intelligent
young people want to do that and go out
and down the line may wind up working
for one Mart many of them right but they
believe very strongly that they
making people's lives better have a
minister friend in Northwest Arkansas
who said who was trying to present one
time to an audience of Walmart managers
and say he said piss Kop alien and he
was saying you know there's some
problems with consumption with American
consumption and with this model that
that Walmart itself promotes and these
largely evangelical managers were all up
in arms and said to him we you don't
understand we're bringing things to
people that no one else would bring them
you know everyone wrote off rural
America as a sinkhole you know we're
we're actually performing a service for
people a service and you've got to
respect that let me just jump in here
and remind our listeners that we're
talking to Bethany Morton the author of
to serve God in Walmart the making of
Christian free enterprise which has just
been released by Harvard University
Press and we're here at the Organization
of American Historians annual meeting in
Seattle having this discussion so you've
just been telling us about students for
free enterprise and this you know
interview story of how these Christian
colleges got funding and and it's it's
kind of a happy story and some ways
urban schools got funding these kids got
business jobs
it all seems good thing your [ __ ] takes
some very kind of dark turn in the later
chapters and you show us this model
getting exported internationally and in
particular you talk about this expansion
into Central America at the time when
there were essentially these civil wars
going on in places like El Salvador
Guatemala and Nicaragua could you tell
us a little bit about what happens there
because I think that we need that
counterbalance one of the strengths of
the book is how you how you handle both
sides but I think listeners might be
really interested to know what the
international side of this story is
about this Christian free enterprise the
Central American story again was one
that completely surprised me when I came
upon and again this is a philanthropic
outreach of the Walton family the
founding family of Walmart where during
the early in mid 80s when you know
Jeanne Kirkpatrick was telling us that
Central America was the most important
place on earth because their communism
was was facing down free enterprise
right in America's backyard as people
said at the time
and the Waltons got interested in this
and had business connections in Panama
and traveled to the area and came back
and set up a scholarship program to
bring young people from Central America
that they were afraid were in danger of
being won over to communism up to
Arkansas to study in Christian colleges
to study business marketing these kinds
of free market oriented disciplines and
then to go back to Central America and
help build a sort of pro-american Pro
u.s. pro free-market alternative to the
left now that's one way to tell the
story but if you if you know the history
in Central America in the 80s it is as
you say a much darker story the u.s. was
deeply involved in creating and propping
up dictatorships throughout the region
that were grossly viciously murderously
lacking in respect for human life for
any sort of values of freedom that we
would recognize as such and the story
seen from this angle is really as you
say much more sinister because not
because one Lord had any direct
connection with that history and that is
important that the evangelical new
Christian Right did have a direct
connection in many cases with some of
these repressive regimes in Central
America and we're enthusiastically
bringing support material support to
some of these regimes Walmart itself had
no direct connection there but what
disappears in a sort of story of young
people coming to the u.s. learning
business Christian values bringing them
home is how necessary the literal
physical extermination that strong the
part about Guatemala where the whole
sort of progressive intellectual class
and students are wiped out but people
who believed in liberal shopping
the grass yeah you don't have to win the
argument you kill the people
dump their bodies at the leftist
universities and there's a vacuum and
into that vacuum people who've been
trained in a very different model and
who has personal experience of the the
chaos and misery of these war-torn
countries in the 80s can step up and say
here's an alternative and and many of
these people work very hard to spread
the the values in the model that they
learned and of course now Walmart has
expanded into Central America the
Central American Free Trade Agreement is
part of the picture so it's important to
recognize what's necessary for this
economic vision to win out is frequently
terrorism you know but there's no other
word for it and covered action I will
say that you had quite quite astounding
evidence in the book so I was persuaded
I'm gonna jump in here and say that I
know we only have a few more minutes and
I wanted to ask you about this because
my own home city of Chicago was one of
the places where there was a big huge
fire a few years back about the siting
of a wall Walmart stores two stores
actually in Chicago and there was a big
local protest on the part of people who
thought that this was going to drive out
local businesses that was going to lower
wages in depressed wages in the city and
on the other side there were people
saying look these are stores coming into
poor communities bringing you know right
bargain prices that hard-pressed
families really need what do you do with
that you know you've written this book
that gives this whole long story about
Walmart how does it affect you
personally very much but you know where
do you stand
well I was actually in Chicago for that
fight and it was fascinating because I
was there at the I guess was the City
Council meeting where the
representatives from the area of Chicago
where these stores had been zoned given
exemptions and allowed to come in was
facing off now against critics of
Walmart who have you know they have the
data Walmart doesn't create jobs it
cannibalizes jobs just like any retailer
does the jobs already
you know they simply substitute you just
shop someplace else it's not a new job
in fact
sometimes the net effect is a loss but
what she said was really important and
people who support labor who have
problems with the Walmart model oughta
listen because what she said was I
didn't hear any of y'all and this goes
back to your own book saying in the 50s
when the jobs on offer were stable paid
a living wage had benefits had pensions
I didn't hear any of you why people
saying that these that those jobs ought
to be the ones we were invited into
because it was a black neighborhood in
Chicago that was bringing Walmart in in
this particular instance and she said
now this is what's left you know and so
you are reaping in a sense she's saying
you are reaping the whirlwind here of
having fought so hard to keep those
stable jobs the preserve of a minority
of American workers of men of white
people of northerners and that worked
great for you for generation and it's
not going to it's not going to cut it
now so I think that particular critique
that sort of no-win faceoff
simply goes back to your own work to the
point that if there's going to be a
viable labor alternative it's going to
have to be a much more inclusive vision
that doesn't think that only certain
people deserve to be able to make a
living by the work they do that only
certain kinds of people deserve benefits
and living wages it's it's got to be
more inclusive I think that's a perfect
place for us to wrap up I just want to
thank you so much Bethany Martin Bethany
is the author of to serve God and
Walmart the making of Christian free
enterprise which is just now being
released by Harvard University Press it
is a terrific read we just skimmed the
surface here so I urge you all to look
more into it because it's really
fascinating work so congratulate